every now and then you come across a
movie that exists outside of the
traditional ideas of good and bad these
are the weird ones forgotten sequels
offbeat ideas in the obscure but
secretly awesome cult classics that you
just can't believe a real trust us
though these movies actually exist and
they're every bit as bizarre as they
sound
karate Bear fighter if movies were
judged by the quality of their titles
1975's karate bear fighter would be
considered one of the greatest films of
all time unfortunately it'll just have
to settle for being the greatest man
verse animal martial-arts spectacular
that most people have never heard of the
story follows the great Sonny Chiba as
masutatsu oyama a karate master forced
to fistfight a bear to the death in
order to raise money to pay for a
child's medical bills admittedly the
actual bear fight isn't that great and
pretty clearly involves Chiba slugging
it out with a man in an ill-fitting
costume but it's still fun to watch and
the best part it's based on a true story
no really a yama was a very real person
who strengths in karate and tendency to
fight bulls earned him the nickname
godhand chiba was actually one of his
students and starred in an entire
trilogy of movies that were very loosely
based on a Yama's life karate bear
fighter is the second sandwiched
in-between karate bullfighter and karate
for life Pottersville to say that
Pottersville is a bad movie is sort of
like saying outer space is cold it is
but it's far more accurate to talk about
it in terms of its boundless mysteries
in the improbable presence of so many
stars based on the title and the
otherwise irrelevant christmas time
setting Pottersville seems like a weird
sort of sequel to It's a Wonderful Life
except that it takes place in the bad
timeline where George Bailey was never
born there's even a scene at the end
that mirrors the heartwarming ending of
the original to my big brother George
the richest man in town except that the
version in Pottersville
involves one of the characters calling a
town meeting to browbeat everyone into
not sucking as humans even that comes
after 80 minutes of a plot based around
a man getting blackout drunk dressed up
as a sasquatch because he finds out his
wife is a fairy who's been cheating on
him with the local sheriff the weirdest
thing about it is how much star power it
has Academy Award winner Michael Shannon
stars
Christina Hendricks Thomas Lennon Ian
McShane and Ron Perlman since it
definitely seems like they're getting
their scenes done in as few takes as
humanly possible it's hard to shake the
feeling that someone was actually trying
to pull off the scheme from the
producers under the right circumstances
a producer could make more money with a
flop than he could with a hit
rubba despite the title 2010's rubber is
not a horror film about an evil
prophylactic although if that's what
you're into you may want to check out
1996's killer condom instead this one's
an 82 minute French movie about a tire
named Robert that comes to life gains
psychokinetic powers and then goes on a
killing spree
because really what else is a tire going
to do it's a weird idea but rubber seems
to draw its inspiration from some pretty
weird places at one point there's a
scene where a sheriff tries to blow
Robert up by dressing up a mannequin and
then loading it up with dynamite in the
style of wily coyote according to
director Quentin de pere though his
biggest inspiration was Pixar's wall-e
sure why not the five thousand fingers
of dr. t TV specials like How the Grinch
Stole Christmas are among the most well
known and beloved television programs of
all time but here's one piece of the
doctor Zeus cannon that's rarely
discussed the five thousand fingers of
dr. T a mind-boggling look from 1953 at
the horrors of piano lessons of course
it might be so obscure because it was
such a dismal failure that Zeus made no
mention of it in his autobiography there
was even a moment on set when one child
actor got sick and led to a chain
reaction of a hundred and fifty boys all
vomiting at once which Zeus compared to
the film's critical reception so of
course it's absolutely worth watching
set in a fantasy world that recreates
dr. Seuss's signature look on a
live-action soundstage the story follows
ten-year-old Billy as he's menaced by a
nightmare version of his piano teacher
dr. terwilliker
in the dream world too will occur strict
music lessons are twisted into a mad
plot to enslave 500 children to play a
single gigantic piano which will somehow
help him brainwash and marry Billy's mum
it's a truly strange film and the
dizzying set designs are as disorienting
as you'd expect but after a recent home
video release dr. T has managed to
become a cult classic going bananas the
canon group could fill an entire list of
unbelievable movies all by themselves
thanks
flicks like ninja 3 the domination
hardrock zombies and Americans cyborg
steel warrior even compared to those
though going bananas is one of the
weirdest movies of all time in terms of
plot it's actually pretty basic a
shockingly intelligent orangutan named
Bonzo befriends a young American boy
named Ben during a safari in Africa
which is referred to as the darkest and
cruelest of all continents because
movies were still pretty racist in 1987
hijinks ensue including Bonzo being
kidnapped by circus flying an airplane
and straight up speaking English and yes
in case you were wondering
Bonzo screeching falsetto voice is among
the worst pieces of audio ever committed
to film
[Music]
according to a documentary about Canon
films the original plan was for the film
to feature Clyde the orangutan co-star
of every which way but loose execs began
pitching the movie to Clyde who and we
cannot stress this enough was an
orangutan they see you and he looked at
the monkey and from now on he kept
talking to the monkey in the end Clyde
dropped out probably because the role
would have required him to speak English
and fly an airplane and the part went
too deep Roy and two truly terrible ape
costume instead thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]